c'est énorme on sait ce qu'il veut faire
oui mais si l'heure de la vengeance de
la société le procureur général des
proches de la république française
[Musique]
on sait que vous avez la musique j'adore
cette musique monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
messieurs les directeurs de la droite
chafouine messieurs les secrétaires
généraux de la gauche social traître
messieurs les représentants des
mouvements anarchistes tendance dior
monsieur le directeur de la boxe
chantante public syrie je ne comprends
pas à ne comprends vraiment pas pourquoi
bernard la valette est actuellement
bellavilliers lavilliers pourquoi claude
lavilliers naples et dans ce box vous
rendez vous contre monsieur le président
que si la justice de ce pays se
mettaient à coffrer tous les chanteurs à
succès qui veulent la révolution
nos prisons ne serait jamais assez
grande pour les contenir tous
d'autre part il ne resterait plus que
mary mathieu et tino rossi pour chanter
pour giscard avant les présidentielles
or mireille mathieu c'est dur et tino
rossi s'est mis
mais enfin quoi qu'il puisse mon côté je
vais maintenant requérir contre bernard
lavilliers mais je me permettrai
exceptionnellement de pas suivre la cour
dans son chef d'accusation non mesdames
et messieurs les jurés je n'accuserai
pas bernard lavilliers d'incitation à la
violence
j'aurais bien trop peur qu'ils me casse
la gueule à la sorte je rappelle à ce
propos à la cour que j'ai une sainte
horreur de la force physique
en fait je suis moi-même non violent
plus précisément je suis non violent non
alignés c'est à dire que j'aime pas
cogner j'aime pas quand on me cogne mais
j'aime bien regarder les autres se
cogner dessus j'aime bien regarder les
autres se connecte eu à la télé alors
que les non violents de gauche
il change de chaîne et que les non
violents chrétiens regarde le christ
mourir sur l'a3 bien de quoi donc est-il
que nous vous l'aurions donc
l'accusation et son client à mettre rego
demanderait ge histoire de paraphraser
gentiment l'avocat de la défense qui ne
m'en voudra pas non j'espère de toute
façon s'il est pas content j casse la
gueule à la sortie du chenal chien à la
cour que je suis non violent mais pas au
point de voir perdre et fluette et que
le premier sous-alimentées qui ose me
narguer pendant la gueule suis armé tout
bien pesé j'accuse bernard lavilliers de
destruction systématique de la faune
bovine française en effet mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
si ce monsieur continue à se vêtir
systématiquement de cuir ne nous restera
bientôt plus de vaches
et cela nous devons éviter à tout prix
que deviendrait le pays de cormeilles
sans les vagues
imagine-t-on d'angor massées criant
rodrigues as tu du beurre et rodrigue
obligé de répondre non chérie il ya plus
de vaches à son tour zouglou y est on en
fait des fûts talent pour bernard la
pick league
[Applaudissements]
imagine-t-on mot belle prairie française
rendu soudain aussi désertique et désolé
que le cerveau de nice femme quand on
lui demande la date de marion
imagine-t-on le défi les contestataires
des bovins place beauvau dans une france
sans vaches mesdames et messieurs les
jurés il n'y aurait hélas pas d'autre
issue que de traire les boeufs et alors
on frémit à l'idée de ce qui se
passerait je vois d'ici les boeufs
prenant le maquis avec léon zitrone à la
tête des forces bovine de l'intérieur en
français et mme pillay
tandis que les malheureux petits veaux
livrés à eux mêmes seraient obligés de
faire l'aumône
non monsieur le président c'en est trop
comme le disait ravaillac à la veille de
son supplice
je sens que je vais craquer la fois par
le malaise ma seule consolation dans
cette vision apocalyptique d'une france
privé ses vaches c'est que pour pallier
la pénurie de protides ainsi créé une
saurions obligé de bouffer ces connards
de bourrin qui court à longchamp tous
les dimanches fouettée par des petits
noah prétentieuse et chamarrée au lieu
d'aller caracoler dans l'herbe comme le
font les shows normaux et tout ça pour
le profit de vieux fossile à gimel et
que deux pics qui ricanent en regardant
le prolo gâcher ces femmes - en perdant
au tiercé
c'est rassurant
défendre la scène je ne sais pas ce qui
m'a pris je les vire et je demande à
l'encontre de bernard lavilliers un an
de prison avec sursis et la confiscation
de ses biens notamment de ses peaux de
bêtes et moreau va bible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non